i'm seth lugo he gets the start for the
mets today 3.75 career era in 12 innings
versus the yankees well he was terrific
his first start he
was able to throw three scoreless
innings perfect innings in fact he's the
first met starting pitcher ever to go
that far without allowing a base runner
but the key is for him to get deeper
into this game today so a lead-off hit
and lugo after not allowing a base
runner in his first start allows a hit
to the first man to face him and here's
luke voight who's six for 15 in this
series with two doubles in a home run
lined off the glove of davis recovers
gets the out at second the turn by cano
and they get the double play
i mean that's a line drive should be
caught but it turns into a
very fortunate double play here's aaron
hicks who hit the game-tying home run
against diaz 1-2
i've got him looking fastball in the
inside corner and lugo has a strikeout
to finish off the top of the first there
he is 21 years old
and he's making his major league debut
yeah last year on a number of different
levels those 165 strikeouts really jump
off the page at you so now dom smith
strike three good first inning
for the youngster davey garcia retires
the match one two three
here's georgella
and lugo blows away her shella for the
first out of the inning second strikeout
for seth
one two pitch swung out and missed
strike three talkman come and go comes
and goes on a 96 mile an hour fastball
lugo has his third strikeout now jd
davis is ready
swing and a miss
good life but garcia just unleashes it
and you can just tell the natural
ability on that 14 fastball toddler wade
leads off in the top of the third kyla
wade hits one deep to right field going
back is conforto on the track at the
wall sia a home run for wade and the
yankees take a one-nothing lead
well a pleasant surprise for aaron boone
tyler wade starting to swing the bat a
little bit here's luke voight who
grounded into a double play his first
trip and make it 10 as he gets voight to
end the top of the third
rosario against garcia as we start at
the bottom of the third
swing and a miss
rosario down on strikes third strikeout
for garcia
a good view of davie's curveball that
we've heard a lot about here's jake
marisnick
strike two more isn't it as he goes down
on strikes the fourth strikeout yeah
this is impressive because this was at
94. in the first inning he was at 90 so
he's starting to pick up velocity ali
sanchez who has one hit in five at bat
so far in the big leagues
strike three he strikes out the side wow
and he's starting to feel it
five strikeouts for davey garcia so
here's kratz who hit a ground ball to
third bases first time up
3-2 coming and he struck him out so lugo
with a high fastball gets kratz
for the second out of the inning his
seventh strikeout it's a gem 14
strikeouts over seven innings
jeff mcneal finds a hole and he's got a
base hit to start
the bottom of the fourth inning the
first met base runner in this game now
he'll face conforto who popped up his
first time up
swinging a miss powered it by conforto
strikeout number six
for garcia smith struck out looking in
the first inning
hit sharply and oh what a play by
estrada he'll take me out at first he
took a base hit away from smith as
mcneal moves to second
so hicks works a walk estrada moves to
second and that'll bring up frazier
and the splitter popped up into shallow
center and mariznick is right there
waiting for it and that retires the side
robbie cannell leads off first pitch
hits it hard right center field that
gets down a base hit a diving stopped by
frazier in the gap to hold canoe to a
single a great play by clint frazier if
he doesn't die for that ball the ball
would have gone all the way to the wall
so ali sanchez will get a turn at bat
pop them up
rachella
and five shutout innings for the 21 year
old davey garcia and his major league
debut so one away now dom smith
lie the other way and dom's got to base
in here's mcneil around third he'll come
home with the tying run dom smith on a
two-strike pitch goes the other way to
drive in the run and the mets get even
at one
we'll see gary sanchez here as the
pinch-hitter for eric kratz
driven deep to left center field going
back mcneal looking up see ya
oh did he need that a huge pinch hit
grand slam for gary sanchez and the
yankees lead 5-1